como esta américa latina y el caribe en
materia de agua y de saneamiento
buenos dias angela un saludo a toda la
audiencia de francés tony ford
bueno latinoamérica no está exenta de
los desafíos que tiene el mundo el
cambio climático nos recuerda la
importancia de tener infraestrura
recipiente y tener servicios esté
adecuados nuestros países durante los
últimos 20 años han hecho un progreso
importante en dotar de acceso a agua y
saneamiento a nuestra población pero ese
es un progreso que todavía es
insuficiente y en nuestra región al 2015
todavía había más de 19 millones de
personas que dejaban al aire libre más
de 34 millones de personas que no tienen
acceso a agua potable y más de 106
millones de personas que no tenían
acceso a saneamiento adecuado cuando
nosotros nos medimos con una meta o con
una vara mucho más estricta como la de
las metas de desarrollo sostenibles hay
más de 450 millones que no tienen un
manejo adecuado de las excretas y hay
más de 200 millones de personas que
tienen no tienen acceso al servicio de
agua potable con servicio continuo este
si uno piensa esos números en términos
de combatir la pandemia
la verdad la pandemia nos agarra
desprevenidos y cuando nosotros vemos
cuáles son los principales desafíos el
principal desafío es acceso tenemos que
asegurar que esos 200 millones de
personas tengan acceso a agua potable
esas 450 millones de personas tengan
acceso a manejo de excretas hay hay
mucho trabajo que hacer en el
tratamiento de las aguas residuales
cuando uno camina por latinoamérica en
la mayor parte de los barrios urbanos no
es poco común ver las excretas esté
siendo dispuestas por las formas veredas
entonces esos son los grandes desafíos y
junto con eso viene una financiación es
infraestructura necesita ser financiada
también tenemos temas de gestión
gobernanza dentro de las empresas sería
derrumbada interior técnico pero es que
quisiera hacerle más preguntas para que
nos alcance el tiempo que usted nos
estaba hablando de las excretas que no
es un panorama poco usual ver que no se
dispone bien de ellas usted cómo cree
que va el trabajo por mejoramiento del
manejo de aguas residuales en la región
mire toda latinoamérica todavía trata
únicamente el 25 de las aguas residuales
que se generan hay mucho trabajo por
hacer el impacto en el ambiente es
importante hay mucha gente que en la
migración del campo a la ciudad este se
asienta en lugares informales y en áreas
muy vulnerables esté cerca ríos o cerca
de cuerpos hídricos para poder tener
acceso que están visiblemente
contaminado